hace dos años una delegación de la
comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos él visitó chile para conocer en
terreno cuál es la situación de los
derechos humanos específicamente en el
país luego del estallido social
sus conclusiones recogidas en 125
páginas son las diarias se da cuenta de
que hubo vulneraciones a los derechos
fundamentales así como también un uso
desmedido de la fuerza de parte de los
agentes policiales otro de los aspectos
importantes de este concluyente informe
es que de parte del ejecutivo
hubo una mirada que puso en duda
justamente la legitimidad de las
manifestaciones al criminalizar las
específicamente hay que recordar que uno
de los momentos más complejos de todo
este proceso fue cuando el presidente
viniera señaló que se estaba en guerra
encontró un enemigo poderoso haciendo
alusión justamente a quienes estaban en
las calles protestando por distintas
causas sociales dentro de estas
conclusiones de la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos se
pone en especial énfasis en la
reparación en particular para las
personas que sufrieron traumas oculares
o daños permanentes productos de los
agentes represivos en este caso la
policía y allí hay un elemento adicional
se hace un foco en particular respecto
de la escasa preparación del cuerpo
policial de carabineros en chile- que
debido a la alta demanda que se debieron
ha obligado justamente a enfrentar
productos de múltiples manifestaciones
no dieron abasto cometiendo excesos que
en algunos casos parecían ser
sistemáticos de allí importancia que la
convención interamericana de derechos
humanos pone uno de los énfasis
particular es la reparación específica
para todos quienes fueron vulnerados
durante este periodo